Wow Oscar you shall have a selective
memory per tradition Sunday nights
Academy Awards telecast feature done in
memoriam segments that honored notable
personalities we've lost over the last
year and also per tradition a number of
beloved entertainment Giants were
inexplicably emitted the Twitterverse
quickly took notice and as you might
imagine folks had some pretty harsh
words for the Academy among this year's
many stubs veteran character actor dick
Miller
it's one of the most notable celebrities
who didn't make the cut expect the scene
in the funnies any day now with smiling
cheque and little Abner he's perhaps
best known for his role in the 1984 joe
dante classic gremlins miller's prolific
career spanned six decades with his
filmography stretching from the 50s
until just last year the pop culture
website AV club also pointed out the
snub noting that Miller's ubiquity as a
character actor sadly didn't translate
to the Oscars the name Gary Kurtz
probably rings a bell although his body
of work isn't exactly a mile long his
legacy lies in a little film he took a
chance on back in the 1970s in case you
somehow haven't guessed that film is
Star Wars which Kurtz co-produced along
with the Empire Strikes Back
not to mention Jim Henson's 1982 fantasy
classic of the Dark Crystal if that's
not an impressive resume we really don't
know what is how could the Academy fail
to mention Carol Channing who passed
away on January 15th 2019 in 1968 the
legendary entertainer was nominated for
a Best Supporting Actress Oscar for her
performance in Thoroughly Modern Millie
[Music]
she's even presented at the Oscars
before and what a thrill it is for me to
fondle an Oscar even in transit still
Channing got no love from the Academy at
this year's ceremony that obviously
didn't sit well with one Twitter user
who simply stated that Channing was an
Oscar nominee over and over until he ran
out of characters can you blame him the
Academy also failed to mention Verne
Troyer who shot to worldwide fame as
mini-me and the Austin Powers films
where was al Matthews who appeared in
James Cameron's 1986 masterpiece aliens
one of the greatest science fiction
films of all time
what about veteran character actor Ali
ma who's scene-stealing performance in a
full metal jacket made him one of the
most memorable film characters ever and
then there's John Mahoney best known Pez
role as Martin crane in the long-running
TV series Frasier that's a lot of
amazing talent but we saved the biggest
omission for last you better think about
what you're saying you better think
about the consequences of yatch that's
right Aretha Franklin the Queen of Soul
wasn't included in the memorial despite
being one of the greatest vocalists the
world has ever seen or heard rather she
had a number of film and television
credits on her resume particularly a
standout appearance in the 1980 classic
of The Blues Brothers you're not going
back on the road normal and you ain't
playing in the MOTU bit sleazy that each
year the in memoriam segment serves as a
way for good ol Oscar to shoot himself
in the foot in that regard the 2019
edition did not disappoint check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and Ted
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]